bienvenue à vous tous et merci d'être
avec nous Moscou à de nouveaux bombardé
dans la nuit Kiev la capitale
ukrainienne tous les missiles ont été
interceptés et détruits grâce à ça
défense anti-aérienne aucune victime
n'est pas déploré il s'agit de la 13ème
attaque de suite depuis le début du mois
Les précisons de Gulliver crag notre
correspondant à le vivre
c'est le mois de mai a été
particulièrement bruyant en termes
d'explosion et de sirènes pendant la
nuit ici elles vivent je me suis souvenu
que les sirènes sont particulièrement
forts je ne sais pas exactement pourquoi
mais le fait d'être réveillé tellement
souvent chaque nuit tous les citoyens du
pays clairement cela fatigue c'est la 1
un impact je pense pas que ce soit le
but principal de ces attaques mais c'est
clairement un effet secondaire comme
vous le savez les services les les
systèmes de défense solaire
Ukrainiens réussissent à abattre la
majorité des missiles presque toutes les
nuits et c'est le cas cette vie aussi
sur Kiev l'administration de la ville a
dit avoir abattu tous les missiles qui
ont été tirés sur la ville les fragments
d'une requête ont légèrement endommagé
le toit d'un centre commercial mais
sinon pas de dégâts majeurs à signaler
pour le moment en tout cas à en revanche
admis pro des explosions ont retenti et
il semblerait que une maison deux
entreprises et une station-service ont
été touchées il n'est pas encore clair
si c'est des fragments d'une requête
abattue ou d'un drone abattu ou si c'est
un drone ou une requête qui a atteint
son cible en tout cas un travailleur de
la station service et blessé selon les
autorités régionales dans la région de
ni pro petrovska ici elle vive c'est
juste les sirènes qu'on a entendu
pendant la nuit pas d'explosion